I'm here in New York City to tell you some big news.
This year, there are four amazing new iPhones.
I'm going to tell you about them...
...and help you understand the differences between them.
One of the biggest changes this year to the display on iPhone 14 Pro...
...is Dynamic Island.
Let's take a closer look.
Dynamic Island is a new way to interact with your iPhone.
When you swipe out of a live activity,...
...the app will magically fly right into Dynamic Island.
Tap and hold to expand it for more controls.
Dynamic Island can even show two activities...
...like maps and music at the same time.
It's the perfect blend of hardware and software...
...that consolidates your alerts, notifications and background activity.
So if Dynamic Island sounds like something you want,...
...you should definitely grab the iPhone 14 Pro or iPhone 14 Pro Max.
All the new iPhones have two brand-new safety innovations:...
...emergency SOS via satellite and crash detection.
While we hope it's something you never have to use...
...if you find yourself in a severe car crash,...
...crash detection uses the all-new gyroscope and accelerometer...
...to measure up to 256 g-force.
When that happens,...
...the feature can automatically call emergency services for you.
That was close!
Looks like no one got hurt.
Except for my dogs.